wait till you see this movie it is
breathtaking it is beautiful and it's
incredibly emotional we have an
incredible film of filmmakers at the
helm
please welcome director Lee Unkrich
co-director adrian molina
and producer Darla K Anderson Coco is a
film that explores the universal themes
of family bonds as well as celebrating
our past we are who we are because of
the people who came before us and we all
stand on the shoulders of our ancestors
and it's so important that we honor them
and to learn from the lessons that they
can teach us Coco is going to be packed
with lots and lots of music it's filled
with traditional Mexican music and songs
as well as original songs that we've
created just for the film though I have
to say goodbye remember me don't let it
make you cry for even if I'm far away I
called you in my heart I sing a secret
song to you each night we are apart
remember oh I have to travel far
remember
starting here as a guitar know that I'm
with you the only way that I can be
[Music]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen plays - Alma and
the voice of Miguel Anthony Gonzalez and
the voice of Ernesto Dale occurs
Benjamin Bratt Thank You d20
you
you